enora et nora va nous chanter du britney
spears avec georges et booster qui ont
préparé une chorégraphie autour de vous
et nora et nora soyez sexy fait rêver
les téléspectateurs 1 et parce que eux
ils vont être très sexy george et
booster pour enlever vos peignoir les
cheriaa allez-y ils ont fait une petite
heure de sport avant d'arriver donc
voilà à lézinnes pouvez-vous peignoir
aller chercher les yeux pour les enlever
oui
attention et doha vous devez chanter
quoi qu'il arrive et doha c'est parti
jégo
et
bbb
m
je ne sais pas
j'vais lui
oui tu es malade ça va arriver enora ça
va booster savent à qui ils transpirent
les gars sur la tête de ma mère j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un vestiaire de
piscine et vous étiez quoi petit bord
avant les chéris il est jugé bien vous
avez très plaisir
oh